it's been nearly 20 years since the
x-men franchise began back in 2000
almost single-handedly kicking off this
whole superhero blockbuster craze over
the course of the two decades there have
been a lot of X movies some good some
bad all pretty weird in one way or
another x-men Dark Phoenix is by all
appearances the final installment in
this incarnation of the franchise and it
goes out with a sense of finality and
closure
unlike the Phoenix referred to in the
film's title it's pretty much guaranteed
that none of these specific characters
or storylines will be picked up in a
future film if you're hoping for a
sequel to come along and elaborate on
any of the dangling plot threads you're
out of luck friend fortunately we're
going to try and do what the never
coming sequel won't figure out just what
it all meant when the credits rolled
here's a spoiler filled explanation for
the ending of x-men Dark Phoenix during
the final battle between Jean Grey and
the evil alien played by Jessica
Chastain the villain says your emotions
make you weak Jean replies no my
emotions make me strong after that she
goes full Super Saiyan flies into the
sky and blows up the bad guy along with
herself
the moment is one of the few times Jean
seems to have full control over herself
her powers and her desires from the
moment she first appears she's unsure of
just about everything when she's in the
car with her parents as a child she
can't control her emotions and she
causes the car crash that kills her
mother later she asks mystique if she's
sure about the space mission safety then
she needs a psychic pep talk from Xavier
to have the confidence necessary to keep
the shuttle together as it's breaking
apart throughout the movie jeans
struggle with controlling or
understanding her emotions holds her
back and causes her to harm her friends
and her inability to process her
emotions is the driving force behind her
conflict with Xavier he put up mental
blocks so she wouldn't feel the grief
over being abandoned by her father when
she finally makes peace with both her
father's abandonment and the fact that
xavier z' mental manipulation was a bad
decision made for the right reasons of
love and protection she's finally able
to take full control of the Phoenix
force and end the alien threat while
Jean Grey seems like she's the main
protagonist of the film she's not the
only character to go on a journey and
grow as a person
Professor Xavier likewise has an arc
that sees him change from when the film
starts to when it ends he begins the
story in a place of power and certainty
in his correctness whenever he issues an
order it's the right call no matter the
cost that others have to bear he's proud
and confident and as the film continues
when he learned that he's also pretty
stubborn in the face of evidence that
sometimes he makes the wrong call sure
Paul Schultz
the turning point for Xavier comes when
he and the rest of the x-men are trapped
in that prison train wending its way
through upstate New York he admits he
was wrong to place mental blocks in
genes mind meddling with her memories
and her ability to process her trauma
and apologizes to beast and everyone
else for his role in genes descent into
a parent super villainy Xavier figures
out that while it's great to take credit
for the good things you do in life you
can't use that to cover up the bad
things you might do as well as a wise
woman once told us you take the good you
take the bad you take them both and
there you have the facts of life the
facts of life
the final scene in the film shows
lifelong friend amis Professor X and
Magneto settling in to play a game of
chess at a public cafe somewhere in
France the two seem to be on good terms
and not currently sitting in prison
cells despite the fact that while the
climax of the movie built up the US
government had plans to establish mutant
internment camps we never really find
out how or why the feds change their
minds on that point especially since in
the aftermath of that big final fight
all those MCU agents seemingly got
killed and their train got completely
trashed but whatever some elements of
ending simply cannot be explained
friends anyway if you're new to this
whole x-men thing here's the scoop on
that final game of chess all the way
back in that first x-men movie we see
Professor X and Magneto playing chess
against one another their match is a
symbol of their eternal struggle they
both want the same thing mutant safety
and security but come at the problem
from opposite sides
in chess the poems go says the to sit
for chess games in several other films
including x-men first class which is
ostensibly the first installment in this
current iteration of the franchise
ending on a game of chess is a nice
touch that longtime fans of the films
will be sure to appreciate
considering this film deals with a
cosmic super entity from space and a
bunch of evil aliens trying to take over
the world there's very little action
that actually takes place in outer space
the climax especially is weirdly
earthbound with a final batch of battles
that take place in on and around a train
if that seems a little odd to you
there's a very good reason the ending
was reshot to avoid being too similar to
another superhero movie that particular
detail came out of a Yahoo movies UK
interview with Professor X actor James
McAvoy who said finale had to change
there's a lot of overlap in parallels
with another superhero movie that came
out well ago
while McAvoy never says which movie
prompted the reshoots there seems to be
ample evidence that the culprit is the
similarly space bound superhero flick
Captain Marvel a film that features a
third act with a massive fight in space
it's difficult to know what the original
ending might have looked like had it not
been Rashad in the end the film is what
it is but if you were wondering why a
movie about alien space gods ends with a
great big smash up on a train well
that's why is this the last time we'll
see mutants on the big screen
simply put No we'll get more X movies in
the not-too-distant future
for starters while this seems like the
ultimate wrap-up to the x-men franchise
in its current incarnation there's still
one more unreleased film from the
franchise New Mutants now that the
rights to the x-men have returned to
Marvel Studios in the wake of the Fox
merger parent company Disney pushed the
movie back to April 2020 whether or not
that release date will stick the movies
been delayed a couple times before
remains to be seen more importantly is
what Disney and Marvel will do with the
mutants now that they're available to be
folded into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe while they've certainly built
an amazing shared universe using
formerly lower-tier comic book
characters like Thor and the guardians
of the galaxy the x-men have long been a
jewel in the Marvel Comics crown the
x-men may seem like also-rans right now
compared to the monumental success of
Avengers endgame but at one time their
movie kick-started the entire superhero
movie craze in the first place
the end of Dark Phoenix effectively
closes the book on this group of
characters but we've seen several
spider-man reboots and Warner Brothers
reboots Batman like it's going out of
style we'll see the x-men in theaters
again before you know it it's really not
a question of if but rather of when and
how check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]